oh
[Musique]
le redescendre juste
ne faut pas du basket mais je pense à
[Musique]
on va faire le rythme du dernier maclan
bush de lui quand vous avez un petit
soucis qui nous le dit tout de suite
qui
[Musique]
ap
à tourner
[Musique]
cette
tête
[Musique]
sur mon toit y adhèrent ou qui vont
l'impression de manquer d'air peuvent
commencer à avoir mal à la tête ensuite
des nausées des vertiges
avoir l'impression qu'ils arrivent plus
hyper ventile ils vont être un peu
manqué d'air et puis après ils peuvent
ne plus avancer 1 commençait un peu à
délirer mais pour le moment
tout le monde va bien
nous compterons vous voyez tout ce bois
j'ai du mal à respirer en temps je te
mais c'est normal puis au fur et à
mesure me suis dit ouais c'était du mal
à respirer maintenant est ce que tu vas
réussir plus haut ça fait angoissé et au
départ j'en parlais aux filles à côté de
moi et puis tout d'un coup il ya le
docteur qui arrive chez mama pourquoi je
n'ai pas appelé il m'a carrément
rassurer il m'a 6 il a pris non quoi
c'est pas ma tension mais il m'a mis le
tricot
voilà il m'a rassuré il m'a pris dans
ses bras et vraiment il a eu des paroles
très rassurante et c'est pour ça que
maintenant je vais mieux je stresse
moins et c'est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le groupe a réussi à monter
collectivement il ya une belle émotion
que les emporter après on a été portée
aussi par
les villageois
même les femmes du village sont venus
non
techniquement c'est pas très compliqué
mais l'attitude bon voilà l'attitude est
un élément fondamental dans la réussite
ils ont appris je pense qu'ils ont
appris
énormément de choses soient bien au delà
d'une des performances sportives est ce
assez
bas c'est le fondement même de
l'éducation il y aura probablement un
avant et un après
[Musique]
où tout est là pour on a pas de blessés
on a pas de malade on a pas eu
d'incident on est des petits trucs ce
qui fait partie de la vie finalement
[Musique]
les bras
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
accompli quelque chose en fait on est là
pour ça on est au sommet ça y est on est
à 4300 m c'est un peu comme la fin en
fait due c'est vraiment la fin mais
c'est un peu le but du projet népal qui
vient de s'achever en fait et c'est très
émouvant et on est arrivés tous ensemble
vraiment est la drôle majorité du groupe
et est arrivée au sommet ça c'est
vraiment un bonheur je le sens très fier
d'être arrivé là franchement c'est
incroyable en plus on a de la chance que
ça se dégage un peu parce que toute la
montée on a eu un temps nuageux
mais wecht heureux je suis trop fier de
moi d'être d'être arrivé jusqu'ici
j'avais certains doutes on sait que
c'est que si on a réussi c'est grâce aux
uns et aux autres donc on remercie tout
le monde et voilà c'est génial et on est
tous très content d'être ici
[Musique]
me sens très très bien je suis très
heureux d'être ici avec tout le monde
voit là bas et je suis très fier
d'arriver ici moi je suis trop contente
parce qu'on la fait tous ensemble on a
compensé le projet tous ensemble et je
suis trop contente on avait hâte ça fait
cinq ans qu'on est seul projet ça fait
plaisir avec tout le monde avec les
portais supporters avec les camarades
les profs franchement merci
[Musique]